what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to geek culture explained
meet steve the plant he's going to be
joining us here for a little while and
rumors abound that henry cavill is
joining the mcu that supposedly marvel
studios is courting this guy in order to
give him some unspecified role so let's
start with the cameo type character this
is a guy by the name of zoran although
those of you guys who are familiar with
marvel comics may know him as sun god
now if you're not familiar with this guy
he's actually a really really cool
character so the way this played out is
during jonathan hickman's avengers new
avengers which i absolutely love
basically you had the illuminati you had
the incursions worlds colliding
different things like that and so what
the illuminati had done is they had
formed something called the bridge in
order to figure out how other universes
were faring against the incursions in
one particular universe they had
actually defeated or fended off an
incursion successfully without using any
kind of crazy devices or anything like
that or at least that seemed to be the
case this led to the illuminati
investigating and coming across what was
called the great society and what you
ended up learning here is that on earth
in this alternate reality you had a
group called the archetypes of justice
which was basically a coming together of
the different superheroes that you're
the most familiar with wolverine and
different characters like that albeit
just kind of a different name but they
tried to defend the earth against the
cree and the scrolls and they were
ultimately killed and so what this did
is it led to zoran and what was
essentially the squadron supreme albeit
by a different name banding together and
then defeating the cree and the scrolls
and then once the incursion started
successfully fending off an incursion
which was a pretty big deal now we ended
up learning later on that they use what
was called the the prisms of forever
glass basically it was their universe's
version of the infinity gauntlet which
of course in every reality whenever an
incursion started and anybody tried to
use the infinity gauntlet in their
universe to defeat that incursion the
infinity stones were destroyed in some
capacity it was basically marvel's way
of getting rid of the infinity gauntlet
as a macguffin to essentially save the
day and so what ended up happening is
when the illuminati showed up here they
fought off fought against the great
society and ultimately they ended up
winning when dr strange summoned this
just eldritch demon from another
dimension this led to basically the
death of the great society and then of
course they ended up detonating an
anti-matter bomb blew up the world and
then left but if we move away from sun
god basically being a cameo character
that uh that henry cavill could play in
the mcu we move into a character that he
could play for the long term which i've
been advocating for quite some time and
that is marcus milton of earth 13034
also known as hyperion now hyperion is
the closest you get to a consistently
appearing character in marvel comics
that's their version of superman
technically they have a few characters
like that right you have hyperion you've
got the century robert reynolds you've
also got adam brashear the blue marvel
but hyperion is pretty much the closest
and the reason why is because even his
origin story at least that version of
marcus milton because there's been
different versions of hyperion that have
appeared over the years in marvel the
origin story of that version of hyperion
was almost identical to superman's that
he came from a world which was home to
eternals in an alternate reality and
that when his world and that alternate
reality was basically destroyed he was
sent to that alternate reality's earth
he landed there and he was taught or at
least raised by a guy named father who
taught him like a moral compass what it
meant to be a good guy different things
like that that story directly mirrors
superman right the explosion of krypton
being sent to earth raised by jonathan
and martha kent and taught what it means
to be a human being that just screws up
all the time and so what ended up
happening here is that hyperion was
basically the last survivor really the
last survivor of the universe when an
incursion started and there was a point
in this comment to show you how powerful
this guy was there was a point in the
story when he held two universes apart
it was only for a few moments but he had
enough power to hold universes apart
from each other now ultimately those
universes collided but he still couldn't
be destroyed and in fact he just sat in
this giant white vacant space that used
to be his universe ultimately he was
pulled out of that space by a group
called advanced idea mechanics and then
he was brought to the main marvel
universe ultimately rescued by the
avengers and then joined the team now
the reason why these two characters are
the most viable options for henry cavill
to play even though there's hundreds if
not thousands of possibilities for
characters that they simply haven't
introduced yet the reason why this is
the most viable is twofold the first is
because it's just a great way for marvel
studios to have henry cavill continue to
play a superman type character and just
kind of jab at warner brothers and just
be like we can make a superman better
than you can but the other reason and
really the most serious reason if we're
kind of getting down to business here is
that the stage has been set for this the
stage has been set for both of these
guys to appear in some form or fashion
the incursions are already a thing
that's going on right we know that
that's already taking place across the
multiverse we know the illuminati have
their explanation for why the incursions
are happening but we don't even know if
the illuminati are right about their
estimation for why the incursions are
happening this exact same scenario
unfolded in hickman's avengers new
avengers everybody thought they knew
what was going on until it turned out
they didn't then you learned about the
ivory kings right the white lords of
wild space basically the beyonders who
were the ones that were behind it all or
at least partly the other part was dr
doom which was amazing
but the big thing here is that if we
want to invoke the incursions which we
are already aware of you can literally
just do the story of marcus milton from
earth13034
as a part of an existing movie possibly
its own film and then have him rolled
into the mcu and he becomes part of
whatever the avengers roster is going to
be that goes into kane dynasty and
secret wars and he's now a part of the
multiversal team you could also do the
same thing with sun god right just say
that like instead of getting a whole
great big huge origin story he's just a
superhero that fights alongside another
team that exists on earth in an
alternate reality and that's basically
all you get another reason why the stage
is set for this is because marvel
studios is looking for what is in effect
the roster for the next avengers team
some of the characters we've already
seen some of them have been teased like
she-hulk i don't know that she's
actually going to be a long-standing
member of the reality i think here is
that while the show is interesting
reception to her character is lukewarm
at best so i don't know if people are
really chomping at the bit and are
excited at the idea that like she-hulk's
gonna become part of the avengers i'm
sure somebody is but the thing about
this is that it allows the mcu to expand
on their existing roster and take
characters that we're already the most
familiar with the incredible hulk thor
different characters like that and add
someone to them or potentially replace
that character with someone like henry
cavill because the reality here is i
just don't see henry cavill as being a
temporary character i don't see him
being a short-term guy i see him being a
long-term guy so having said that uh let
me know what you guys think down in the
comments section let me know what you
think this role will be for henry cavill
do you think it'll be either one of
these do you have your own guesses on
who you think henry cavill is going to
play and if you do make sure you post
those below thank you all for watching
and i will catch you all later
peace